Kubernetes is a platform
for managing your containers.
Machine learning workflows
can often get really messy,
especially in production,
so it was only a matter of time
before somebody put the two together.
How do we do machine learning
on Kubernetes
without too much extra work?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to AI Adventures,
where we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode
we're going to check out Kubeflow,
an open-source project
to help make running
machine learning training and prediction
on Kubernetes clusters easier.
The Kubeflow project is dedicated
to making deployments
of machine learning workflows
on Kubernetes simple,
portable, and scalable.
More specifically, it wants to allow you
to easily deploy your code
to all sorts of environments--
from, say, your laptop
to a desktop with two GPUs,
or, say, a training Kubernetes cluster
versus a production cluster.
And, of course,
this wouldn't be Kubernetes
if it didn't allow you
to scale everything with demand.
Kubeflow began life
as a way to open source
TensorFlow Extended, or TFX,
which was how TensorFlow is run
internally at Google.
While it was originally just a simpler way
to run TensorFlow jobs on Kubernetes,
it has since expanded
to become a multi-architecture,
multi-cloud framework
for running entire
machine learning pipelines
with many contributors,
all across the ecosystem.
This might be a good time
for a little confession.
I myself, I don't know
a whole lot about Kubernetes.
Having spent the past several years
focused on TensorFlow
and data science and machine learning,
my Kubernetes skills are...
well, they're not exactly top notch.
So I'm really hoping that Kubeflow
can allow me to deploy TensorFlow
and other machine workloads
onto Kubernetes successfully,
because I do hear Kubernetes
is pretty great!
So, let's see what it looks like
to use Kubeflow, shall we?
Kubeflow aims to be able to run
anywhere Kubernetes can.
This means everything from your laptop
to bare-metal servers
all the way to the public cloud.
For now, let's check out how this works
on Google Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
Installing Kubeflow to GKE
is actually shockingly simple,
since there's a click-to-deploy
user interface.
All I had to do was enter
the project ID of my cloud project,
give my deployment a name,
and choose a zone to put it in.
Then, all the necessary resources
were provisioned automatically.
Now that is my kind of deployment!
So with Kubeflow installed,
and the UI accessible,
you're ready to dive in
to the world of Kubeflow.
You can train models,
visualize them with TensorBoard,
serve models, build pipelines,
and log in to JupyterHub
to manage all these things.
Most of the time we get to use
the very same training code
that we would be running locally anyway,
and just add some configuration files
for the Kubeflow-specific parts,
and then you can run them in Kubeflow
with no code changes.
I can perform training
on my Kubernetes cluster
using Kubeflow,
and have the exported model
either stay on disk
in the Kubernetes cluster, or send it off
to a Google Cloud Storage bucket,
allowing me to easily share
or deploy the trained model
to systems outside of the cluster.
Alright, that's enough of me talking.
If you're interested in running
machine learning pipelines
on Kubernetes,
then it's time for you
to get started on Kubeflow.
I've linked to a number
of codelabs and resources
in the description down below
to help you get started.
Thanks for watching this episode
of Cloud AI Adventures,
and if you enjoyed it,
be sure to hit that like button
and subscribe to get
all the latest updates
right when they come out.
For now, head down
to the description below
for more information about
how to get Kubeflow up and running
on your Kubernetes cluster.
♪ (music) ♪